Throngs of people jammed Saint Peter's Square, the boulevard leading up to it...
...and nearby piazzas for the special beatification mass at the Vatican.
Thousands camped out all night and took part in an all night prayer vigil at Circus Maximus.
People from all corners of the world prayed, sang hymns and waved their national flags.
Many were Polish who came to honor their native son.
Attending the ceremony were 90 official delegations and 16 heads of state.
Also among the crowd was French nun, Sister Marie Simon-Pierre,...
...who says she was miraculously cured from Parkinson's disease...
...after praying to the late pope.
With our apostolic authority, we announce from now on,...